here we are in the SpaceX machine shop
when Elon Musk founded SpaceX in 2002 he
only had two things going for him SpaceX
basically consisted of carpet and a
mariachi band that's all of SpaceX well
he did have one more thing an ambition
that knew no bounds
the sky is not the limit for Elon whose
mission is to send people to Mars
on April 20 2023 Humanity took one step
closer to that dream when the world's
largest rocket the fully reusable
Starship attempted to go into orbit for
the first time obviously this is uh does
not appear to be a nominal situation
although Starship failed to reach orbit
learning from failures is elon's
approach to his career building SpaceX
and to think he built a rocket company
with just a bachelor's degree in
economics and another in physics Elon
who was Canadian citizenship thanks to
his mother may began his undergrad
studies at Queen's University in
Kingston Ontario three hours East of
Toronto he chose Queens over Canada's
University of Waterloo which is renowned
for its engineering program because as
he told Queen's magazine there didn't
seem to be any girls at Waterloo I
didn't want to spend my undergraduate
time with a bunch of dudes after two
years at Queen's he transferred to the
University of Pennsylvania as he thought
attending an Ivy League school might
help him land a job in America the land
of opportunity when it comes to Tech
still built degrees in economics and
physics weren't enough to make him a
rocket scientist so Elon taught himself
by devouring these books a habit he
built as a boy reading the entire
encyclopedia when he was only eight or
nine years old he also absorbed
Knowledge from the industry's best he
cold called Aerospace consultant Jim
Cantrell who answered while driving in
his convertible with a rooftown he
thought he heard Elon introduce himself
as an internet billionaire as he
recalled in an interview with Esquire
Elon wasn't quite a billionaire then but
he did score 180 million when his
financial services company x.com merged
with PayPal which was bought by eBay he
then sunk everything into three projects
100 million into SpaceX 70 million into
Tesla and 10 million into solar energy
companies SolarCity which later merged
with Tesla in 2001 he planned on buying
a refurbished intercontinental ballistic
missile from the Russians to use as a
launch vehicle he figured his space
Ambitions could start with sending some
mice to Mars the Russians wanted 8
million per ICBM twice what Elon was
prepared to pay when he countered with 8
million for two Jim Cantrell recalled an
Ashley Vance's biography on Elon that
the Russians reportedly said something
like young boy no
Elon apparently stormed out of the
meeting on the flight home he broke down
the cost of building and launching a
rocket on a spreadsheet he realized a
modest-sized rocket that could carry
smaller satellites and Research payloads
into space could be much less than 8
million so SpaceX was born with a goal
of building its own Rockets it is an
understatement to say starting a rocket
company is hard but Elon found an ally
in The Godfather of rocket science Tom
Mueller Tom worked for the large
Aerospace company TRW at the time which
Northrop Grumman later acquired he spent
weekends building and firing rockets in
the Mojave desert in California as part
of an amateur rocket club The Amateur
rocket scene was tight and Tom got
introduced to Elon
Tom designed the Merlin engine that
powers spacex's Rockets basically this
engine will burn a hole right through
concrete Merlin revolutionized space
flight as it's designed to be reused
Elon understood that the only way to
open up space to everyone was to
drastically cut costs by building
reusable Rockets the Falcon 9 is
partially reusable as the booster lands
back on Earth before the Falcon 9 there
was the Falcon 1. the Falcon 1 attempted
to launch for the first time on March 24
2006. it lasted only 41 seconds in the
air before crashing due to a fuel leak
the second attempt the following year
went slightly better but the rocket
failed to reach orbit due to a chain of
issues caused by an unexpected bump when
the first and second stages separate
third time wasn't a charm either as a
timing error caused the two stages to
collide Elon had run through all the
money he had set aside for SpaceX when
you had that third failure in a row
did you think I need to pack this in
never
why not I don't ever give up
I mean I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated he told
his employees to keep going
the then head of talent acquisition at
SpaceX Dolly Singh recalled on the
question and answer site Cora Elon said
quote we need to pick ourselves up and
dust ourselves off because we have a lot
of work to do then he said with as much
fortitude and ferocity as he could
muster for my part I will never give up
and I mean never and that if we stick
with him we will win I think most of us
would have followed him into the Gates
of Hell carrying suntan oil after that
it was the most impressive display of
leadership that I have ever witnessed
while Elon tried to save SpaceX Tesla
was hanging by a thread he joined Tesla
in its infancy after sinking Millions
from his Paypal earnings and stepped
into the role as the company's board
chair after numerous management
shake-ups he was left in charge as CEO
in late 2008 and a time when Tesla was
in serious trouble the production of the
first vehicle the sporty Roadster went
way over budget by October 2008 Tesla
had just nine million left to fund the
company it was hard to convince
investors to Fork over millions more
during the worst financial crisis since
the Great Depression his personal life
fared no better he was going through a
divorce from his first wife Justine with
whom he shares triplets and twins Elon
has said 2008 was the worst year of his
life with SpaceX unable to get his
rocket into orbit and Tesla nearly
running out of cash it looks like one or
both of his companies would die as he
painfully recalled to Ashley Vance
I could either pick SpaceX or Tesla or
split the money I left between them if I
split the money maybe both of them would
die if I gave the money to just one
company the probability of it surviving
was greater but then it would mean
certain death for the other company I
debated that over and over it felt like
having to choose between two children
perhaps his difficult childhood shaped
his never give up mentality he was
bullied for years when he was growing up
in Pretoria South Africa one day in
eighth or ninth grade he and his brother
Kimball were sitting on the top of a
flight of stairs eating when a boy snuck
up behind him kicked him in the head and
shoved him down the stairs then a bunch
of boys beat him up until he blacked out
the beating damaged his nose so severely
that it restricted airflow he later got
surgery to correct his deviated septum
his life at home was no less painful
after his parents divorced Elon opted to
live with his father for a time but he
told Rolling Stone that his dad Errol
was such a terrible human being you have
no idea my dad will have a carefully
thought out plan of evil he will plan
evil Elon found comfort in coding
sometimes programming throughout the
night at age 12 he coded a space-themed
video game called Blaster a South
African magazine published The Source
Code and gave him 500 bucks the game was
no Marvel of computer programming but it
did hint at his underlying Brilliance he
turned to science fiction fantasies into
reality when he founded SpaceX at the
age of 30.
failed flight attempts an investment
from a venture capital fur made it
possible for SpaceX to attempt a fourth
flight the future of SpaceX rested on
that fourth launch on September 28 2008
the Falcon 1 lifted off 9 Minutes 31
seconds after launch the rocket reached
orbit
confirmed
the success saved SpaceX because it
helped secure a 1.6 billion dollar
contract from NASA to resupply Cargo to
the International Space Station SpaceX
was out of death's reach but Tesla was
still within its grasp as Tesla was
running out of money Elon devised a plan
to keep his company afloat he cut 25
percent of the workforce and leaned on
friends to cover the weekly payroll he
managed to scrape together 20 million
including money he made investing in his
cousin's data center startup which Dell
bought the year before investors agreed
to match whatever he was able to get on
his own this new round of 40 million
dollars in funding save Tesla on
Christmas Eve it was the last hour of
the last day that it was possible Tesla
would endure many more years of pain
after going public in 2010 at 17 a share
although the model S wowed the world
people hesitated to buy the luxury
vehicle after it came out in 2012. Elon
turned his employees into sales people
whose job was to convince anyone who put
down a five thousand dollars deposit to
go through with your purchase when
orders weren't coming in fast enough
Tesla said it was temporarily shutting
down its Factory for maintenance and
kept the real reasons secret to avoid
spooking investors and sending the stock
plummeting elon's maneuvering worked in
2013 Tesla stunned Wall Street by
posting its first ever profit elon's
goal has always been to build a more
affordable electric car but Tesla simply
couldn't keep up with demand for the
model 3. frankly we're going to be in
production hell and as the saying goes
If You're Going Through Hell keep going
Elon promised to produce 5000 model 3s a
week initially yet only managed a mere
800 cars a week in the first few weeks
of 2018. Tesla was burning cash as it
tried to increase the production of its
most affordable car Elon says Tesla was
about a month from bankruptcy the
situation was so critical that he slept
in his factories to save time and he
also said it was for more than his staff
he told Bloomberg whenever they felt
pain I wanted mine to be worse the pain
eased as Tesla found a way to claw its
way out of danger once again Tesla
managed to increase production and turn
the corner as it entered 2020. it is now
expanded from one Factory in Fremont
California to factories worldwide Tesla
delivered 1.3 million vehicles in 2022
and one of them was my own
as they drove across Canada last summer
I couldn't help but think that one day
electric cars will be so run-of-the-mill
that they'll just be called cars
I did notice that supercharging stations
across the country were pretty empty
there was basically No One charging
beside me yet charging stations will
soon be getting busier many countries
including Canada have mandated that all
new cars and light duty trucks sold be
zero emission Vehicles by 2035. not to
mention other auto companies will now be
relying on Tesla's charging Network like
Ford Elon has stressed that Tesla must
make its cars fully autonomous in which
there is no human intervention at all
like that's really the difference
between Tesla being worth a lot of money
and being worth basically zero as Tesla
Engineers work to improve its full
self-driving technology it wants to
place that technology in a robot Optimus
perhaps felt like a sideshow when Tesla
first unveiled it in 2021 however those
who are insightful or looking to listen
carefully people understand that Optimus
ultimately will be worth more than the
car business worth more than FSD there
has been arguably even more skepticism
over elon's plan to ease traffic by
putting Teslas into his own tunnels
we're still years away from seeing
whether the boring company's tunnels
will be a Visionary mode of
transportation or if there are too many
holes in elon's plan it's also too early
to determine the potential of neuralink
which received regulatory approval in
May 2023 to test its brain implant on
people neurolink's chip is meant to
stimulate the brain and help those with
spinal cord injuries control their
computers and smartphones with their
thoughts
we have a chance I have size
chance of being able to allow someone
who
um
cannot walk or use their arms to be able
to to walk again the long-term goal of
neuralink is to merge humans with AI
a common theme runs through all his
companies the dream of freedom from
Earth by going to Mars freedom from
fossil fuels freedom from traffic
freedom from the limitations of human
biology and now Twitter is fighting for
freedom of speech which he felt was
suppressed under previous leadership
Twitter has changed its Incorporated
name to x-corp to move toward elon's
plan of transforming Twitter into X the
everything app that includes making
Twitter a better video experience and a
little announcement I'm now posting all
of my full videos on Twitter where I'll
also share exclusive Tech insights you
can catch me at newsthink or click the
link in my description although Elon has
been building many of his companies for
over a decade their potential is only
just starting to emerge regardless of
whether he succeeds or fails he won't
give up he once said when something is
important enough you do it even if the
odds are not in your favor
it's incredible that Elon coded the
blast star game at the age of 12.
although it was impressive it's also
amazing to see how far we've come since
those early days of coding simple games
well raid Shadow Legends is an immersive
online experience when raid reached out
to see if I was interested in trying out
the game and having them sponsor one of
my videos I was curious I never expected
to get this level of performance out of
a mobile game raid Shadow Legends is a
fantasy themed role-playing game there
are loads of powerful Champions I
especially like Elaine because she's
focused on dealing as much damage as
possible to enemies and consistently
Landing critical strikes there's also an
epic limited series raid call of the
Arbiter to celebrate raids adding some
of the new characters from the series as
Champions you can play with in-game the
first one is our attack a mighty orc
warlord who is available to everyone for
free all you have to do is log into raid
for seven days between now and July 24th
if you're new player use my custom link
in the description or scan the QR code
on your screen and get a free starter
pack with this cool in-game loot thanks
for watching I'm Cindy Palm